hi I'm Alex and this is my recipe for
crispy rice cereal chocolate cheesecake
it's a mouthful of a title so I have
been wanting to do a video using rice
krispies treats in a new way for so long
because they're actually malleable and
you can make them into different shapes
which means you can do just about
anything I also am pretty obsessed with
cheesecake as you guys may already know
so I decided to pair the two together so
because the flavor of rice krispies
treats marshmallows I decided to lean
into the chocolate cheesecake because
it'll kind of bring together a s'mores
flavor which is a classic I use the
measuring cup but you can also just go
in there with your hands to press it
down into the springform pan originally
for some reason I thought you could bake
rice krispies treats and you can't I
wanted to do a classic baked cheesecake
so the first time I made this I made the
rice crispy crust
I poured in the Cheesecake batter I put
it in the oven and then disaster struck
so I ended up burning the original crust
in the oven so I realized that I had to
go back to the drawing board but
actually it was easy to fix because I
could just make a no-bake cheesecake so
cheesecake lovers may argue that the
only real kind of cheesecake is a baked
cheesecake but you can yield similar
results by making a no-bake cheesecake
and it is a little bit easier to do so
in a big cheesecake the eggs are gonna
stabilize it whereas anomic cheesecake
you have to use a different stabilizing
agent so a gelatin or in my case I use
the chocolate and whipped cream
so in order to make the crust out of
rice krispie treats you have to make
sure you're working pickly because
they're only malleable when they're
still warm those are really the only key
things to remember for this recipe
other than that it's a pretty simple
cheesecake just a lot more fun now once
you make the cheesecake and you cool it
you can stop there but I decided to
decorate it because I really wanted to
go the extra mile so if you're eating
this by yourself feel free to stop here
but because I was bringing this to a
party I decided to go the extra mile
and decorate the top I know this recipe
is so sweet I'm not telling you to eat
it every day but you know for a treat
for a crispy treat it was a winner I'm
not the best decorator but I really
tried to focus here and make sure I
nailed it we only had one shot now if
you're concerned that your rice krispy
will get too hot while you're cooling
the cheesecake once the cheesecake is
set pull it out and leave it on the
counter for a few minutes and your rice
krispies treats off and right up and
there you have it snap crackle pop is
that like trademark they can't trademark
word right yeah
[Music]